good morning believe nation today's
message is have the courage to pursue
your idea over to you Malcolm Gladwell
awake mood in espresso TV go it's not
enough to have a great idea and the
focus and the conscientiousness to see
it to fruition you must have the
strength and the resolve and the courage
to pursue that idea even when the rest
of the world thinks you're insane time
and time again if you look at the
stories of extraordinarily important
entrepreneurs there is almost always a
moment when they are the only ones who
believe in the value of what they're
doing it can really suck to be an early
stage entrepreneur it sucks because you
have a vision for what you want to
create you have a vision for a world
that doesn't yet exist and nobody else
around you gets it right even the people
who may support you as a person and
believe in you as in general as a person
may not see where you're going and you
definitely have the little man the
people around you saying oh that's a
stupid idea that's never going to work
it really sucks to be an early-stage
entrepreneurs because often you'll see
it so clearly and you want you don't
understand why nobody else can get it
and they don't and it's super
frustrating because you have to create
something different and that's what
entrepreneurs do entrepreneurs are the
people who stand up and say you're wrong
and I'm going to prove it to you and I
sincerely hope that you aren't the kind
of entrepreneur that lets that big dream
die within you because you didn't have
the courage to chase it and instead you
were swayed by other people's opinion of
you so the question of the day today is
where did you get the courage from to
launch your business and chase your idea
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press 0
expresso keep me going